hello everyone and welcome to another
really great game from round one uh of
the tata still 2021 uh between anish
giri and
the other norwegian in the tournament uh
grand master aryan tari
uh it's uh quite a lovely game and i'm
sure you're gonna enjoy it so uh let's
dive straight into it so giri uh with
the white pieces opens with
e4 uh we have e5 by tari uh sorry about
that
uh and knight to f3 by geary so knight
f3
knight to c6 and bishop to b5 gary goes
for the royal lopez
knight f6 we have the berlin defense
pretty much the only thing anyone
plays nowadays against the royal opus in
top tier tournaments
d3 and now bishop to c5 we have bishop
captures and c6d
captures uh and now geary castle so this
is all
i've been seeing plenty of times we have
bishop to g4
uh and now h3 kicking back uh tidy's
bishop we have bishop to h5
and now uh it's a very interesting
position for example uh first had it
against magnus carlsen in last year's uh
saint louis blitz tournament where
knight beat to d2 was played uh carlson
was able to win this with with the black
pieces but here we have
a very daring g4 and now
it's very interesting what you do here
do you retreat with the bishop bishop to
g6 or do you
capture on g4 maybe with the bishop or
maybe with the knight
so this position has been reached before
so this is not a new move but it is a
very tricky one
and the one very important uh piece of
information
is that in top tier games uh black never
won this position so it's very
uh very interesting that uh tari goes
against this against someone like anish
giri who is
i think probably the most prepared
grandmaster in the world i don't know
the the extent of for example carlsen's
or dubose preparation but
uh i i would guess gary is uh you know
really
really among the absolute most prepared
so here he goes and accepts the
challenge
knight captures on g4 you want to keep
the bishop so you can
continue pinning the knight h captures
we have bishop captures on g4
and now already a very very uh critical
position so to say
not not really a critical position but
it is a very important one
so basically the two moves that you
consider here are bishop to e3
you you already grabbed the piece too
you want to trade more
or kink the g2 now king to g2 is
something that
most players usually play you want to
make room for that rook you want to get
the rook into the game
but it's already very dangerous for
example if black castles and you now go
bishop to e3
now black just busts open the position
with f5 and you're going to have a
a very very difficult game to play so
white will now be on the defensive for
the rest of the game
and even if you grab a piece here then
it's just game over on the spot pawn
captures and there is no defense here so
many pieces are attacking the knight
here
white's going to lose the queen and
there's not much to be done even with
perfect play
which i'm going to show is it's very
interesting uh you can capture on e4
black can actually trade queens here
first captures captures bishop captures
with
check and now king has to move you're
going to capture on f1
bla white will capture on f8 and now
you're going to capture back here
and even if you don't go into any more
complications it's just a winning end
game white is a black is up to pawn so
uh easily winning so after bishop
captures on g4 you have to be careful
like
there are some choice choices but uh
giri goes for the uh
absolute best one which is bishop to e3
and now black of course didn't castle
just yet so maybe
f5 would be a bit too ambitious so here
bishop back to e7 that he wants to keep
of course as many pieces on the board
now
he sacrificed material for the attack
and only now king to g2 by giri
uh and f5 immediately striking uh in the
center and trying to open up the f file
uh
for uh attacking the the king uh we have
queen to e1
uh immediately getting the queen out of
the way so now the knight can move
and now bishop captures an f3 uh we have
king captures on f3 and now look at this
beautiful king here he's a quite to the
adventurer
uh and now uh what do you do here uh
well
uh you don't wanna you don't wanna
capture here capturing doesn't really do
all that much
uh so what do you do here here black
tries to keep the pressure on the board
by playing
f4 now he uh kind of uh
uh kind of numbs down the the power of
this dark square bishop and he wants to
play
g5 h4 g4 next and continue the attack on
the white king so gary has to go back
bishop d2
and now g5 and here gary just switches
the bishop to c3 now
uh putting it on a very nice diagonal
attacking the uh the pawn here on e5
and now uh here bishop to f6 tary just
defends it but
if you're playing a position like this
you you always have to check moves like
g4 does it work do you get anything by
opening up the g
file because it's very interesting for
example king captures
rook g8 to check now king back to f3
only move that doesn't lose
and now how do you continue the attack
for example queen the seventh
threatening checkmate
but then white survives after king to e2
and now the king will find safety for
example czech king can go king to d2
and now white is just up too much
material and the white will win the game
but it is it is very interesting and
my point is you should always check
moves like these so
bishop to f6 atari defends the e5 pawn
and now
knight to d2 and geary continues
developing uh we have queen to e7
adding another defender here at some
point this knight is coming to c4 i'm
gonna
attack the e5 pawn once again and now
rook to h1
we have h5 by tari and now king back to
e2 want to start running away with the
king
g4 looks very scary and now f3 by giri
that's why king the king d2
now he can play f3 and black definitely
doesn't want to capture here because
this is just a
a perfectly fine position for white so
instead after
f3 toddy continues pushing we have g3
now creates a very strong pass pawn here
but gary doesn't mind king to f1 and now
gary will put his king on g2 put his
rook on h3
black does not have a light square
bishop and he will create a very nice
blockade here on the king side
and the black will have a very hard time
uh breaking through this so
h4 and now uh rook to h3 you do not want
to allow h3 then it's uh
then it's all black so rook to h3 a must
move and now comes
a5 here again you need to check g2 just
you know maybe it works maybe it doesn't
but you need to check what's happening
after rook g8
uh check king h1 it doesn't seem like
black has
that many options but you know always
check so here
a5 and now of course we're going for
for b5 and further expansion but geary
immediately goes a4 he wants to place
this knight on c4
and he wants the b5 square uh defended
so so the
the knight cannot be kicked away uh you
know just like that
so b6 and now kink the g2 uh we have c5
by starting and now
queen to b1 now you can play b3 you can
bring the queen here and
then the queen the bishop and the knight
will all be attacking the e5 pawn so
here
king to f7 atari needs to play some
moves
but there aren't all that many moves to
play here and it's a
it although it seems like it's black
who's attacking here it's actually white
who's attacking here because black has
these two weaknesses the e5 pawn
and the h4 pawn and it's going to be
extremely difficult to defend all of
them so b3
rook 8 to d8 and now knight to c4 so a
second attacker joins the attack we have
king to g6
and now queen to b2 now a third attacker
joins the party
so now you have to defend it rook to h5
this is how tariq defends the pawn
uh rook ate the h1 now with uh
more pressure on the h4 pawn for the
moment it's sufficiently defended so
it's not a problem
rook d the h8 adding another defender
and here
queen back to a1 by geary uh we have
king to g7
now bishop back to b2 king to g6 and now
queen to b1
a little bit of maneuvering placing the
queen on the same
diagonal as the king so now maybe c3 and
d4 will be
uh possible here uh but uh tari uh says
no not a problem we're just gonna go
rook to d8 and now
uh we add additional protection to the
d4
square and also i'm gonna move my king
on the next move so we don't have to
worry about this
so queen the e1 by giri uh now
switching the queen over to uh to the c3
square
and then he's gonna move the knight and
try to wiggle his queen into the
position
like this so it's quite the plan rook
queen king to g7 and now queen back to
a1
uh here we have rook d to h8 atari just
uh has to wait and see what geary will
do
and now gary starts re-maneuvering with
the knight knight to a3 and now you can
go to b5 you can go to c3
you can even go to d5 if you like uh you
can go to e2 if you need it for some
reason we'll see what what happens
so king to g6 and now knight to b5 tarry
has no option here but to wait and see
what geary will do
bishop to g7 and now knight back to c3
uh we have queen to d8 and now not
knight to d5 although it is a nice
square for the knight
uh instead giri goes knight to e2 and
here already you can see that there
might be some tricks here queen and
bishop
uh here on this long diagonal maybe
knight f4 will be an idea if pawn
captures then
you might uh you know completely uh get
your position destroyed
so here rook ate the h7 adding a
defender to the bishop here
and now queen to e1 now that um
gary achieved this now he's going to try
and uh
make way for his queen to enter black's
position queen to d6 and now
queen to c3 uh we have c6 by black and
now queen to c4 so keeping an eye on
that b5 square also preparing queen a6
and here we have rook back to h8 again
it's very hard for black to make a move
here
uh for example if you try something like
let's say bishop to f6
then you allow queen to ga to check and
this is something you don't want to
allow
because after king to g7 now queen to e8
check
you have to block this otherwise you
might lose the rook
so let's say rook to f7 and now rook
captures an h4
very very tricky stuff rook captures
rook captures bishop captures
and now the very nice knight captures on
f4 and
uh that's just it for black he captures
queen g8 to check the bishop covers this
square so you cannot block
king h6 queen captures and now black is
just completely busted
uh so uh very tricky to find a move here
for black
daddy goes back rook to h8 and now
bishop to
a3 aligning the bishop with the queen so
d4 is the idea here
daddy moves the queen queen to f6 and
now finally queen to a6 going after that
pawn
so tardy defends it rook to b8 and now
bishop to c1
uh again a lot of pressure on that f4
pawn you need to do something about that
so toddy defends it bishop to h6
now queen to a7 attacking the rook if
you move the rook again you're gonna
start losing the pawns on the queen side
and since the the kingside is completely
locked down there's nothing uh to be
pushed there
if you lose the queenside pawns it's
game over so queen to d8 keeping an eye
on the rook
and now bishop back to b2 again trying
to overload black's defenses for now
everything is
defended but now there are three
weaknesses for black to worry about and
uh more often than not two are enough
three are just impossible to hold
so queen to c8 and now comes queen to e7
you don't really have a move here like
uh this is a
uh i don't know if it's if it's
officially too swung but
uh the the black really does not have
any moves here so here
queen to c8 by tari and now gary goes
queen to e7
and this is the almost the position from
the thumbnail
uh if you don't do this for example uh
if you try something like uh
rook captures on h4 uh rook captures an
h4 and rook captures an h4
rook to b7 uh white is still of course
winning but
uh black manages to kick away the white
queen and it's going to be
uh it's going to be uh
you will have to grind a little bit more
with white so here gary instead goes
queen to a7 he doesn't allow his queen
to be kicked away uh from the
from the seventh rank uh and now bishop
to f8 so
why did gary allow bishop to f8 and get
his queen trapped because the queen has
nowhere to go all of these squares are
covered
uh you could go back all the way back to
a7 but if you go queen to a7
uh then rook to a8 and then again what
do you do here
again not and none of the squares are
available now to the white queen and
you're just gonna have to
gonna have to give it up uh but it's
still it's still a very interesting
position so i will show it
for example white can go bishop captures
an e5 here and after the queen is
captured
now knight captures an f4 with check
connects with the rook and after the
king moves knight captures here on h5
and it's just a complete madness of a
position uh but
it's in fact white who's still better
here but it doesn't matter because after
this bishop to f8 move agiri has
actually a forced checkmate in seven
so feel free to pause the video and win
this game for gary
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
absolute
best idea and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
uh it's knight captures on f4 with check
so immediately go for this this is what
geary played and it was in this position
that arientari resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh
why can't you do anything well let's
explore what happens if you capture the
knight if you capture the knight
then you've opened up this diagonal and
then it's just over uh
there are actually two winning moves
here queen to f6 is winning but
the much nicer rook captures on g3 is uh
is more beautiful so we're gonna see
why this is more beautiful if h pawn
captures
then you just go queen f6 check and now
you opened up the h file for the row
king h7
row captures king here and of course
rook to h8 is checkmate
so why don't you capture with the f pawn
you might ask
well this also is possible but then you
free up this diagonal for the bishop and
this is
the good stuff queen f6 check king has
to move king h7 queen f7 you're gonna go
king h6 and now
bishop the c1 with check
and there are no moves for for the black
king rook to g5 and now
rook captures here is checkmate the rook
is pinned and
nothing can move here and just awesome
awesome stuff
so what you could do after this knight
captures an f4
that ended the game is uh ignore it you
could just move the king king to h6
but it's not much better queen f6 check
king to h7 and now queen g6
is possible because the knight guards it
king to h8 and now
bishop captures an e5 an excellent
finish
uh rook captures and now rook captures
on h4
and now once you give everything up
along the h file it's just uh this very
nice checkmate
so uh everything came down to this
knight captures an f4 move uh
which is uh one of my favorite moves the
knight captures on f4 uh because you
know that
game six uh uh botweenic versus stall uh
really really a nice one uh even though
that was a a
black knight capturing on uh uh on f4
but still you know it's knight f4
uh but yeah another nice game from round
one and the winners uh after the first
round were
grendelius geary and carlson who are now
officially leading the tournament after
round one but we're not going to be
showing the the
uh table because it's only round one
we're gonna show it maybe after
after the third round uh so yeah uh
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it really really awesome stuff by gary
and here you can see that what happens
it was actually tari who thought he was
attacking but it was actually giri who
was attacking once uh once uh
the king side completely uh closed up uh
it was it was actually white who was
attacking all along
uh but yeah uh the great stuff from tari
for going
for such a wild attack against giri uh i
i hope he continues uh playing such
games because those are the games that
we
uh uh most enjoy seeing uh so yeah i
would like to thank
andrea quirini olson hisa tiziano
danny justin brockhouse for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the tata still 2021 uh
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day